I shouldn't be holding on to the mic
like that like hi Eric
hello I'm like happy Monday to everybody
we are checking out a game today that
admin trend in Australia review for us
gave it a 9 out of 10 and you've had a
lot of fun playing it over the weekend
so you asked me this morning like hey
what are we streaming today cuz we got
this cool game called
into the breach I got take off that
session I yeah I put the bottom right
all right I can I can move that while
you're getting into it so this is the
kind of long-awaited follow up to FTL
fashion light which came out in 2012
from subset games the music you're
hearing right now is also still been
print II who did the synth driven iconic
soundtrack for FTL that game came out in
iOS later on and a lot of people that
got an even bigger audience there this
right now is just thought PC I got it
through GOG but you can get it on steam
comes out tomorrow yep $15 I believe I
believe that's what we saw from their
tweet from subset games yeah yeah I will
so it's a tough game to show off I will
say off the bat yeah go read ads review
9 out of 10
this game is unreal as someone who
really likes turn-based strategy as you
know I like XCOM - Jake has gotten me
into Fire Emblem over the last year this
game is in FTL I'm a huge fan of FTL in
this game is you could definitely see
the influences um there's still
roguelike elements much like with FTL
but whereas FTL was more about like you
said kind of a APM real-time yeah
because like so much [ __ ] would be
happening in your ship like there's a
fire here you gotta like close off like
a you know like possibly like a broken
part of your ship that's like letting in
like bad space air and something I'm so
excited so I love you this is more like
chess as a lot of people are saying it's
turn-based and you get to plan out your
text you know what the opponent's gonna
do beforehand so you have to react to
that but you get a team of three mechs
you're essentially fighting kaiju it's
kind of a specific Rim yeah and as you
get different achievements right here
you get coins and so I've played I
played enough to unlock this squad the
rusting halts which are really good and
this squad and as you go through it's
it's all about time travel too so you
get to pick one
so there's the three mechs and then
there's three pilots in each of them one
pilot in each of them and you get to
pick one pilot to survive until your
next playthrough so you bring him
I'm travels back and you go into the
next playthrough so that's the that's
like the rogue legacy kind of a
progression element that doesn't die
each time so I turned off the toriel's
but I'll walk you through so you go
through each island this is kind of like
um you play to FTL you get that star map
you're going through so it's all it's
all like a post-apocalyptic super future
earth after it's like flooded and
there's different timelines that you're
defending against the Veck that's the
name of the alien kaiju kind of things
nice so I'll skip over that story stuff
well that's pretty much it up here you
see the power grid my number one
objective is to not let this reach zero
if that reaches zero that's the end of
the playthrough um so you see here you
get the whole okay so say if I go here
to the research center and defend this
you get a lightning which is another bar
but you can also lose it during and then
a star is reputation for this island at
the end of the island once you defend
the corporate HQ you'll get to spend
that reputation on mech upgrades and
whatnot
no cool these are I don't see any there
usually you can get reactor cores but
there are none available inside I can
buy them with reputation but those are
used to I'll show you right here so
you'll get different weapons here and
say I have one reactor core I could put
it into here so he can move one if I
three reactor cores I can put it into
here and he would get +1 damage with his
tank cannons nice so you're it's I mean
if you played a roguelike it's not
nothing
I'll go uh I'll do this one sounds good
and so they're all like these mini chess
board kind of pieces then the you get
two bonus objectives so if I end the
battle with less than four mech damage I
get one star reputation to spend at this
island and if I defend the coal plant
which is the building right very
important yeah yeah it's there they go
back to coal in a few here apparently
cool there you see the Veck I'm gonna
try to do as little talking as possible
but this game is yeah despite how simple
it kind of seems there's a lot to it as
you can kind of see from the HUD the
only thing that are pip is blocking and
it's not huge is uh if I hover over a
certain tile type I can show them real
quick yeah so it'll say like coal plant
this provides power or forests if
damaged lights on fire you do fire down
it just tells you the tile effects and I
guess I can describe them okay I've been
to the desert and the snow planets bring
us back here alright here's my Mac this
is like the melee one I'll drop him here
tank is more like an all-around medium
kind of he can shoot in he's
he can attack like a rook on in chess
like any direction sideways and this is
artillery they I'll show you sounds good
so hello to everyone in chat thank you
guys all for tuning in for those asking
what game this is it's into the breach
it's a new game from the developers of
FTL you know so here so you can see what
their moves are gonna be so right now
all three of these are concentrating on
those more clinton yeah and then that's
where like a lot of strategy comes in
because like you can push them over
those and then they'll get damaged and
that alien won't be able to pop up
better so right now all three of them
are focusing on the coal planet and
that's not good no so what I want to do
get Ralph in there so here like I can
I'll have him and then I'll punch this
one so next turn he'll attack his buddy
now well realize I just knocked him into
it same with this dude I think and you
can cancel the moves if you don't like
him
like I don't like that um I'll undo that
one so this where the strategy comes in
like you can always push them a lot of
it's like enemy positioning and stuff so
I'm so like ideally you'd want to push
well maybe not maybe not push the fly
into the the other guy that's coming up
but because that other guys gonna attack
them but you could in theory do that
right like push him into that that space
behind him yes like if I had a different
if I had a different squad there's one
so the artillery will hit him and then
adjacent tiles will be pushed oh so I
could kill him right now cuz he's low
that might not be my best move keep in
mind you're expected to die in this game
so I'm gonna screw up a little bit he's
dead or he will be dead he'll be dead
and then you can look at the attack
order so he's gonna attack first so
he'll damage the building before he gets
hit so I don't even know what I want to
do I kind of like don't have a good
placement so they're gonna hit all
should it's good because I'll show you
how you lose all right Aris game so I
don't have much to do with him I'll just
enter and that just says I have an
action left but I can't really do it
what's up Josh how you doing he says hi
to both of us so there you go so the
power the coal plant is gone one of my
bonus objectives I'm not gonna give that
bonus energy at the end and I also lost
a bar to the power because your main
objective is to protect the cities the
civilians let's reset I feel like we
already failed no no I'll show you how
okay so so now
this green one that came up he buffs
everybody and you can see they all have
extra hearts oh geez they like doubled
up in heart yeah yeah okay so here's
what I want to do I want to kill him
Jeff carrier currently I believe it's
only PC but yes it would be fantastic on
the switch is video so this is just
another example I hit him over so he's
got one health left and I'm gonna punch
this dude into him to kill him and now
he's dead and the buffs are all gone
nice yeah we this is not gonna go well I
might really survive them and scroll on
those other two on the bottom okay yeah
okay
so they didn't double my bad there's
only one extra everything and so
artillery can has to shoot two tiles
away and then it like pushes things out
so I'll damage them a little bit but
they're still gonna attack it so it's
very likely that I'll lose I mean I
might not lose completely on this map
but I'm not doing well at all if you
play this game and her casualties yeah
oh no power loss - oh geez yeah this is
definitely how you lose quick I guess it
the game gets tough but you like learn
and also like I said I unlock the second
squad our third second and third so you
get three new Mexi time and I also in my
current playthrough at home I have like
a really good dude that I've brought
through a lot of playthroughs um
so another another like valid thing you
could do is I know he's gonna attack
that way if I just move I'm gonna dodge
it it's not gonna even be a problem but
what I want to do is yeah so if you go
there's a good on ya now so I'll take
one damage but I'll stop him from coming
out and also I'm gonna knock him away
from her in the building and into his
line of fire so I'm gonna keep that like
that because that's fine he's gonna die
he's gonna just whiff now what I want to
do this gets us so he's not webbing him
I can move so I'm gonna do this and I'm
gonna attack him he should die nice and
then I'm just gonna pretty much get out
of his way I think actually no kind
either oh why not yeah okay but I'll be
in good position too so this return I
didn't nothing bad happen in fact it'll
kill him
I mean he'll whiff there we go yeah and
also unless they are flying a bug Beck
you can knock them into water and they
just die Oh
sweet I can move into water all my young
web all my things can move into water I
just can't attack from water so he's web
so I can't move but I can punch him
Witter ioniq unfortunately no um
giveaways Josh the same potentially
video with a lull well face yeah well
face for sure sup mr. Jarrett 46 thanks
for tuning in
we were playing into the breaches uh
just a quick Mike's pretty much just
showcasing you know the different things
you can do what the monsters do just
kind of a quick little chat about the
mechanics of the game see if we survive
this one if not we like you said we just
start another one it's fine currently
not doing so hot but I believe in Mike
oh I'm gonna let him take that hit I
think yeah I mean I have to yeah unless
I could I could hit him Technic but I
this is the dude that's worrying me um
what happens so I want to attack ed so I
could attack here but my tanks there and
now actually I could do that anyway
alright you know I'm gonna do I'm gonna
get crazy I'm gonna hit her I'm gonna
hit my tank I'm gonna push him away save
civilians but guess what he's gonna
shoot him he's gonna die in the next one
so you lose the pilot but you keep the
Mac as long as you survive the
sacrificial lamb yeah
so that's disabled basically to win each
tile set you just have to survive but he
barely just lost but I completed the
mission great so we could reset but I
want to show you what happens when
things go bad because they I could turn
around yesterday I had a playthrough
where I was at one and then I started
gaining him back all right but so toi
Volkov died
he's ki a mount AI goes into the tank
the cannon mech so I didn't do anything
either the bonus objectives the AI worst
then like a pilot um yeah you can't they
don't you can't like take AI into the
next timeline and they don't the pilots
don't rank up from what I understand oh
this one's cool so tidal waves it's an
environmental effect so at the beginning
of each enemy turn these waves are gonna
disappear in water and kill any enemy
that doesn't fly so what I want to do is
kind of maybe plan for that and just
like I want to say on this side to kind
of hit them into the water because right
now the I'm trying to protect this coal
plant
and take less than three grid damage so
if they hit the buildings three times I
don't get that bonus reputation going to
spend at the end so I'm gonna keep him
here on my tank here and my artillery
here see I you have an AI in the tank
over here that Jill yeah I don't know
okay webbing Dart
so actually this one's dead he's fine
because that tidal waves gonna kill him
next time so I don't even have to worry
about him okay at all so what I want to
do is knock okay this this is you like
this I can hit him into there he'll
block that one he'll die but also block
that and I think I just screwed up no no
no I didn't so I'm just gonna dodge him
cuz he's gonna miss and him I'm just
gonna move him over here okay so he high
waves gonna kill this guy he's gonna
whiff
he's gonna die oh and he attacked the
guy that's coming out
no no the guy didn't come out yet oh so
pretty good I just what I want to do is
take care of this dude who's buffer
buffer let me see if I can do that so
this is where I people are saying it's
like chess because I could move and
attack and kill some but then screw up
the rest of my turn what I want to do is
try to knock him into one of these tiles
if possible but I don't think I can
because I would have to hit these
buildings to push him in so I don't want
to hit him up here cuz he's still gonna
hit those buildings I want to hit him
down here if possible
well hello beza from Syria thanks for
watching hi from Iraq says thanks so I'm
just gonna dodge him I think yeah so I'm
gonna hit him no one with him first
so yeah if you guys have questions for
Mike he has pretty good knowledge over
the game so he were there during this
weekend and now Oh sick okay quick cool
so this actually worked out so I'd
knocked him over one and two so now he's
dead and now he's gonna whiff and I can
hit the buff dude I don't think I'm
killing but I'll at least knock him oh
that was really dumb
I should have knocked him over that
space either way so would you have to
aim with square rub it in - okay okay
either way that was still not a bad
round this dudes close to dead I got a
few more people but they're only on the
water so the flying ones as you could
see you can go above water and still
attack as it's so these two are dead but
that still doesn't solve the problem of
this wasp dude so what I want to do so
yeah I want to kill this next compass if
ik rim you know I'm gonna do I'm gonna
knock him into him so then I so he had
three left but I killed the buff dude
and I set this forest on fire and now
he's got one left we're gonna do the
finish it off I don't know I don't know
if I can actually oh you know what I can
so he can stay there he's not yeah I'll
hit my tank a little bit but that's fine
so he'll hit him that he'll dodge the
buildings now my tank took some damage
but I'm like I'm gonna let him attack
the tank I think who attacks you so
those buildings might get hit but that's
fine I could take a little bit and I
would assume if the bugs some like pops
up in the water or the tsunami they just
they just die yeah so he's gonna miss
he's gonna hit him he's gonna hit the
buildings okay but we can we can afford
one grid damage yeah yeah cuz I'll still
get the bonus the tank took a little bit
but that's fine I'm almost done after
this turn there we go
wasn't bad at all we gained one power
coming back yeah a little bit and then
red much I can also spend reputation on
power at the end if I choose to do so so
I'm back at 2 it's still not great but
better civilians protected that's like
your your score at the end but I
protected the coal plant completely so I
get the power and I took a less than
three grid damage I took one mm-hmm
thanks to the tidal waves and this dude
got a new skill so uh one mech reactor
so you can go over here so I just got a
reactor core so I can install that in
anything so if I had to I can put it
into the - I'm gonna put it into just
for now move so he can move one extra
space good Cretan Minotaur currently
just out on PC Mac OS and Linux not on
the switch yet even though a lot of
people are saying yeah I'd probably be
great on the switch I think even you
said it'd be easy game to put them on or
play on switch is a little Spencer $15
this it like this might not be conveying
it yet but this this game is very deep
you get more than just these three mechs
after you do get achievements and
there's a lot to this game despite its
kind of simple look there's that little
missile turret thing is that was that
new or did yeah that's new so that's I
can use it it's not as powerful as my
artillery but so you want to defend the
artillery unit for reputation and I want
to protect these batteries for power but
I can use him I just don't want him to
die so maybe he's like a glass cannon
kind of gene more it is a steam game but
it's also on GOG and so I'm playing on
GOG yeah I know comes out tomorrow GOG
was kind enough to give me a coat over
the weekend and then a pod so I can
secure that for bonus like attacking for
upgrades and stuff there's webbing do
anything to a city that just means like
if if any of like the non-flying ones
are about to attack something it will
mainly show up as webs okay so I want to
just immediately punch him away because
that also saw he'll hit the mountain
instead what else do I want to do move
him here and then attack
him and set the forest on fire so he's
dead
it was um I still the tank move what I
could do here move him over her over
here hurt kill this dude actually while
I'm at it are you going to secure that
pod or do you just do that later because
it's pretty safe right now
that's pretty safe right now yeah so
right actually no I don't want to hit
him because I would knock him into that
I think I'm just gonna let him with but
I could move the tank into a better
position actually no I'll secure the pod
it'll tell me what I got from it later
on so I protect the pod I get those yeah
so he's gonna whiff two more guys will
come off that's fine though I already
have an angle on one of them and if they
do end up in the fire square or also
landmines later in the game and ice
mines they'll just take whatever effects
you might expect like fire damage or
they might get frozen gotcha okay so
this is a good opportunity to let me
figure this out so if I move out of the
way this dudes range will hit that
building so I'd probably want to knock
him away I got a question here so that
the jec Nova says they noticed there was
a custom squad option would certain
mechs be immediately accessible or do
they have to be in LA no so what happens
is you'll unlock a new squad and then
you can mix and match so I could take
two of these dudes and one from another
squad so you have to unlock at least one
other squad at least one other to do a
custom squad yes sure
so bear with me cuz I'm trying to figure
out the best way to do it like I might
take I would take longer if I was uh at
home like just relax and not on a stream
so this is tough cuz there's a lot going
on right now these are in danger in
these kind of artsy I might take it as
hit okay
cyborg oh that's a very different game
but he was like I know a kaiju game it's
EDF different not as deep strategy so
he's fine I'm gonna like it in this
dudes way too I could kill him I think
that's what I'm gonna do this won't kill
him but I'll hit him
and then I'll get in his way knock him
in the mountains this you're killing
because one the bullet did one day I'm
not in the mountains so I'm gonna have
my my my boxing mech take that hit I'm
gonna move my artillery back here no
buildings take damage this is going well
so I haven't eaten anything oh yeah I
say that now so I got three more turns
ideally I would have liked to block one
of these whether it would have been with
my max or with the Veck mm-hmm Oh
so they got a buff which I can kill
easily because he's near mounds if I get
over there in time which it doesn't look
like I'm gonna be able to I would much
rather have him try to attack my max
then while he's near the rocks there
yeah so would your take but they're all
blocked blocking it um unless hmm you
know what I could do so he's no dammit I
was gonna do a little this boom now what
else can I do
oh here we got me blast and boom Oh so
look at all this damn yeah I'm gonna go
look it cuz I'll knock my tank into the
buildings so I'll just hit him my tank
will take damage but the buffle be gone
and that bug okay cool
sweet so still no Billy now I'm just
gonna can I kill him no I'm just gonna
nope undo that hmm how much damage is he
gonna do 1 damage so it he's not gonna
destroy the artillery unit still
wouldn't like to take that damage though
have you punched anything yet you could
kill that guy assuming I could though
cuz if I if I stay here I'll take damage
but otherwise he'll hit the building's
[ __ ] with him I'm gonna have that
very far gonna hit this Bam Bam oh it
hits two squares yeah that one does and
also oh I could kill him yeah I could
call him but I'll still take a hit but
that's completely yeah but so do you
feel like you're you're favoring like
your main dude and trying to like
protect him because he's the one that
like my only one of the punching one
protect yeah um he's just the one that
like has the most health fair air
yeah he has the most health and he's
also just better up close huh so it
depends on the situation like when I get
my new squad that has this one jet and
they're they're focused on the smoke
attacks so you can put smoke on it on a
tile and then that pretty much just like
lets them
they just can't do anything that round
so here we go
oh [ __ ] actually when you undo that so
here's the problem here no that's not a
problem all right
yeah you can kill him so he's dead he's
fine buildings are fine I'm gonna free
up my Mac because he's webbed BAM he's
gonna just hit the mountain that's fine
I could probably kill him actually this
is a problem yeah cuz can you get him
out of there so that they don't hit the
building so he's fine so I'm gonna bring
my mech my Fox went here kill him ooh
too damaged new um she's gonna move my
artillery to better oh no I just I just
finished the mission because I didn't
want to turn left and the turn and he'll
hit the mountain and we're good so I
guess I get power and reputation look at
this starting from a deficit no problem
but last night I I got to the fourth
island and I had full power I had all
three mechs were pretty well upgraded
with like a few reactor cores and all of
a sudden these this boss came out and
get me
so here's the pod you open the door give
me a reactor core for an upgrade and
he'll give me like a medic ability so
it'll tell you which class it works for
so this is for any of the three mechs
cuz there's like this is a brute this is
ranged and this is uh I forget what it's
called but there are different types so
I might want to use that so I have one
reactor core to spend I could give it to
my tank heal all player units cuz I
forgot to mention if you want to repair
oh that's not even take okay cool sweet
so I have that is that is that
proximity-based or is it just like you
do it and then like every one of your
teammates get kind of that it I think
it's just like a global okay so now I
just use the second reactor core to do -
so now is yeah I can - it's more
powerful and I don't know what the
there's no distance okay so now so now
he can attack like much farther he's
much more range in his attack this so
this is the last one I'm gonna do before
I few defend corporate HQ I guess like
in terms of it's either this one or this
one
defend the tanks defend the Train I'm
gonna defend the tanks that sounds like
something I can use to my advantage
yeah I can use the tank space and when
do you unlock another unit is it the
next based on achievements yeah yeah so
if I finish this island at home I I
think I've I've gotten two extra squads
I'll get a coin and you can spend that
on new squads
Oh two tanks you get two Issei you have
to use those Siri I think so no if not I
just have to protect him okay so they've
already got a buff I don't know which
side are gonna go to I'll put my close
range ones on there and my artillery web
Fox 100 wants to know what any of the
mechs have similarities to other
franchises have you noticed any of that
in there there movesets at all
yeah I mean like if you play RTS games
that they're kind of like the
traditional like artillery medium tank
and like up close
maybe like total war or like Warhammer
or even Starcraft almost kind of like
that rock-paper-scissors so no I can't
use the tank so I have to protect them
okay so I'm gonna go here well BAM okay
so the buff is gone but I'm gonna move
him back here to dodge that and I'm
gonna hit him just to get him away from
that building now he didn't die so he's
gonna take fire damage so I don't think
I need to waste a bullet or a block one
of those guys that would probably be the
best yeah so he's gonna whiff he's gonna
take the fire damage I hope yeah so
he'll take the fire damage and then
that's essential it'll just take new one
damage and he's dead there we go
so otherwise if he survived that he
would have hit those buildings but I was
fine arson well he took one damage but
he blocked it so now I just it's more
manageable for now this one is new so
it's much more it's easier to deal with
so I'm going to
hmm trying to see if there's a way I can
Danny that tank was in there I could
knock him and have him cover up a hole
but I think I can manage them a few of
them coming up he's dead race we don't
deal with these guys I have to hit him I
guess oh okay you're fine cuz he's not
gonna hit any I'm just gonna move in
here I think I in turn so yeah like you
can see my tank my medium tank has that
he'll ability now but right he's the
only one that's damaged you can see over
here okay cool
and uh we're getting closer to like a
boss fight around the corner finding the
corporate HQ so I'll show you some of
them cuz they're like some tough dudes
to kill do they are they different each
time
um it depends on the island so one
island will always have a beetle boss
the snow island which hopefully we get
to today this one will have like a just
a purple version of one of these guys I
have a more upgrade it like more health
more damaging kind of so here's what I
want to do okay kill him easily knock
him into the water he's dead yep I'm
gonna move here attack here push all
them out of the way sounds good actually
now take one damage but that's fine [ __ ]
that was dumb why was that dumb cuz now
he's still you know though he's gonna
die now I'm gonna so you can reset turn
once it's since it's a time travel you
can reset a turn once so that was dumb
so like I can't do that
no it's once per a battle battle okay so
that's pretty clear
yeah or we can I know I know the fire
move him yeah good call I'll punch him
in the fire so he'll die from the now
he's dead hmm undo no I think I'm still
good
okay I might hit him directly and I
could try to kill him um man I might
have to what the buildings take a little
bit just not enough to all the buildings
are fine right because you also save
this you see grid defense 15% there is a
50% chance the buildings will not take
damage yeah very rarely though I could
but then he's still gonna take one I'm
gonna knock him into the fire he'll
absorb this dude
attack okay I'll take the damage there
and I can heal up at all at some point
is that everybody no I don't think you
use artillery because we did that hot
reset you know at the very least no cuz
I don't want to build buildings to take
damage it sounded like there are
different environments but do they do
those actually take oh that was dumping
whatever no I can't
once you attack you only can I think
it's everything let's see what happens
maybe the buildings will resist this I
might lose this playthrough so fire
damage no he's gonna hit these resist
we're just it okay so actually that's
good I can show you the time travel ass
oh [ __ ] in the air but they're here yeah
Bob Jones each island but next once you
unlock an island you could do them in
any order on each subsequent playthrough
but they'll scale based on where you're
at there's a snow and ice island there's
a desert island where you can terraform
the land with like grassland and desert
and kind of screw up some people so I
survive 24 minutes I'm gonna take this
to you because he has more he gets bonus
xp and he already has a reactor I'm
gonna take him so now he comes into my
next playthrough if I had finished that
island I could get a new school I'll use
squad but I didn't and then you can
customize a squad and take one from like
whatever ones you have unlocked dies oh
do that that fourth one had a
cool-looking guy right yeah blitzkrieg I
really like these two this squad I use
that a lot yesterday that was the one
that got me the most achievements um so
I'll go this one the rift walk is again
I'm bringing Ralph along with us okay
this is a serious run yeah it'll be
slightly hopefully slightly easier the
beginning because Ralph is so like once
on each playthrough say I beat this
island mm-hmm on the next player I could
just start there and it wouldn't be as
hard and then this one would scale okay
this is the last island you unlock but
if you like beat the game you can go in
the next playthrough and start there the
ice ones cool because you can actually
mess around with the ice environmental
stuff but oh we missed using the tank my
bad I was in that you can blame it on
the copilot the tanks had actions
available damn okay okay cool thank you
that's good to know I didn't it wasn't
no I saw you click it but it just had
assumed that it well that would have
helped us survive thank you guys I'll
keep that in mind turns out you did it
the hard way
hi previously
so this has air support I've never done
that before let me try that all right
take less than three get damaged protect
the emergency batteries which are right
in the center of the map there's gonna
be tough but I get air support so let's
see how that works I think if it's like
lightning oh yeah okay so each turn
they'll do random spaces so I got to try
to push them there and avoid them so
it's like close air support I put my
mech close to the batteries as well as
my tank and keep my weird on doing my
artillery keep them mobile back here I
guess back there you get it up you can
get an ability later where you can drop
them anywhere on the map and they'll do
damage to adjacent tiles like Helldivers
you ever play that see in halo yeah
okay so there's gonna be air support
there so that dude's fine I don't have
to worry about him because that's gonna
kill him
I think it'll kill him yes killing any
unit on there so he's a problem right
now so is he hmm I'm here's what I'm
gonna do
so I wanna knock any bush has me yeah
well I'm bad um he's not gonna get
knocked back he might the tank might
take damage no you know I'm gonna do I'm
gonna undo that so you lost your heal
ability thing right soon yes correct Mac
this is weird that might have been dumb
let's try to figure this out so I can't
knock him he's gonna take a damn and Ray
I don't mind taking a damage yeah I'll
just attack him and push my tank nope
can't do that either because I'm he's
gonna hit those buildings I think I'm
just good okay so he's gonna get bombed
here
well he'll yeah yeah he'll die well he's
dead he's gonna take two hits who that's
fine though it's more important that you
use like it's more important that Ralph
survives right now cuz he's the one with
the progress I would say I mean I don't
want to prioritize them but yeah
actually you kind of have to
it's like rogue not real like it's like
darkest dungeon almost where you have to
accept people are gonna die or XCOM I
don't know whatever you want compared to
you um sacrifices will be made yeah so
this dude is in trouble but just gonna
knock him out of the way there I want to
take out this buffer apparently yeah
they had indicators that popped up above
that one's active but appears you got to
protect them to get that point okay so
I'm gonna let my mech take damage here I
think yeah you got it I could kill the
buff but I don't want because that not
lose the emergency batteries yeah
he's dead nice um sweet saying we're off
is a beast yeah next he doesn't have
that - anymore but he still has the
reactor core that used to power it I'm
hoping I get a good airstrike in the
next turn like right here would be great
nope no same exact terrible spot okay
that's not good he's ever seen what's
dead
I think he had three but maybe I'm wrong
okay hopefully not hmm ooh wow that's
okay good so I gotta think about this
one the tank is almost done I can knock
him into the fire I want to take out the
buff but what's the best
direction he's definitely gonna die if
you punch him with Ralph's ready yes so
what I could do it was not I can knock
him into the path of that dudes there we
go
so he'll die huh hmm so I think
buildings are gonna have to take yeah
but I mean that's why I get a Mac out of
you right here so yeah I mean I'll lose
a bar but I'm trying to think so he'll
die he'll attack him turn order yeah um
fire damage though it's the thing is
there a possible way so I got I have to
choose between nothing's gonna not just
do by the way did you use the tangka can
you push the or yet can you push the guy
into the fire no I'm going to yeah I'm
just gonna I'm Charlie I decide who I
want to let him know
ah [ __ ] oh no no does he attack first
dang it yeah he's gonna hit that
building so I was hoping that this dude
wasn't he only have one health left yes
always teased a lot but I was hoping so
if this dude attacked before him he
would kill the buff that would go back
down to one then the fire would kill him
I'm gonna take some damage but not like
game ending so he's gonna hit the
building fortunate way to beat [ __ ] crap
crappy tactical strike so this dude I'll
hit the buildings he's dead yeah okay so
he's dead but he still hit the Billings
first okay cool
so well still getting so get a boat so
you knit net loss was one net loss yeah
one they're assuming you still get the
bonus which I assume you're probably I
look like I'm in good shape you just win
anyways cuz victory in one turn or do
you have to do I mean there's still
things I could do to prevent if yeah
pretty much now it's all just dodging
cuz I can just knock him out of the way
you know I'm gonna have fun with this
one and knock him into the air strike
screw you
[Music]
he's just gonna whiff I'm gonna knock
him out of the way um air strike I'll
kill him
if you get preferences at all to like
there are some bonus objectives that's
like okay I'm just wondering if we get
anything for actually killing them all
before the end of the round you do yeah
yeah it's just that's it's hard
sometimes it's sweet I got the bonus
reactors I lost two bars to my power but
that's better than how we saw last time
like I said you only really lost one cuz
of the bonus right yeah up here I got a
reactor core for upgrades experience all
around Ralph's got more because that
bonus cool um what Fox wants no well
therapy microtransactions I doubt it and
can this be played offline
yeah I'm offline right now I'm not
offline but yeah you can play it offline
I'm assuming well know if you even have
to sign into steam well you don't have
to be online
well we haven't tested that and there
are no [ __ ] there's no tomorrow
feisty but yeah I highly doubt there
will ever be micro transactions knowing
I mean subset games I'm only basing on
FTL but maybe they'll bring this to this
and FTL be awesome on switch as well as
low bundle yeah this this coming to iOS
I would not be surprised because they
brought FTL oh yeah it's on iOS yeah
it's a that's what it says at least
those platforms is gonna be Windows Mac
OS and Linux okay for those just joining
I'm trying to pick between getting to
reputation to spend at the end or
getting power I'm pretty set on power
but well you get that's like the best of
both worlds there right you get a little
rep you get and I got an hourly to mess
with okay deadly Aquila says can't wait
to get tomorrow yep it does come out
tomorrow just so you guys know I'm just
a pawn dollars right now okay protect
those buildings shields not meet shields
mech shields I cannot came into the
water I mean get you good shape I like
this map the water down here on their
side is should help me out I'm kind of
excited to see hopefully we get through
here so we can see another type of oh
yeah I'm gonna try to get the rusting
Hulk's oh and a new squad yeah okay so
easy I'm just gonna nah I came into the
buff dude he's gonna hit him walk this I
guess yeah
shoot him away oh no whoops problem I
might just have to take that just fine
because I can't attack on to the
adjacent square with artillery oh no I
can do this oh that's my tank sorry I
can do this
but ma'am see if he didn't have that
buff I'd be fine but he has the buff so
he's gonna hit him I don't think there's
much I could do there ah can you hit the
buff guy so I could knock him into me
and then he would be at one health I
would take a damage but I'm trying to
think who would attack first him err oh
no he's the first attacker no I'm just
gonna take his ticket yeah it's better
than the building's getting hit in the
long run well he'll can't take much more
that was actually good because he
wouldn't have killed the buff okay cool
so I tried knocking some dudes into the
water so if like okay so you know how
like if one of those mechs had one life
left but it's due to the buff if you got
rid of the buff do they die yep okay
cool that's what I was trying to do last
time but I forgot anyone even killed him
so he's being a pain what I want to do
here he's web he can't move damn this is
weird so I don't want to knock him into
that building hmm could have my tank
take a damage I guess I think I'm gonna
do this
that'll make things easier in general
and that can take another damage there
won't be a huge problem but I'd like to
avoid it the Jack Nova wants to know are
the items power up single-use it's not
necessarily single-use power items and
power-ups it depends on some so when I
equip a secondary ability I'll be right
here it'll say like one-time use and
then you can upgrade it to time or it'll
just be infinite depending on how
powerful it is um like this this is fine
I can take damage I don't want to knock
him into those buildings though mr. Choi
yeah although avoid the tank damage to
sweet oh okay I was like wait you're the
water back but he's fine yeah
mr. Cho gamer you can get this on steam
tomorrow as well as the dog little
switcheroo got him okay so he's gonna
block he didn't take one more damage
just fine though it'll prevent someone
from coming up we're doing pretty well I
mean could be better but yeah we're
taking some damage but that's okay
that's Ralph's though just so that Ralph
died yeah I'll start knocking some dudes
oh so these two I can knock in the water
didn't kill him okay so I do not want
well your the other artillery does two
damage well does one damage on two
different tiles or maybe those do two
names oh you're right to tell us okay
let me undo that now that I know that
what do I want to do with him
I gotta get him off that space he's
gonna get messed up
Wow into the fray yeah closer you're out
of danger the farther you are from harm
I don't know it's for my holy rings
there you go kill him so those buildings
are fine
could kill him I don't want to know I'd
push artillery can I do that
I don't know if artillery survives in
the water actually my dad I don't know
I'm just gonna go
actually it should tell me I can't I
don't know but we're fine
didn't want to check for science huh
well it there is a way to tell it just
like his turn was over sort of status
effects weren't showing up I think we're
fine right no so artilleries threatened
I couldn't move him kill him okay no I
can't okay so that's good I didn't rely
on that last time these two I'm gonna
mmm can you move your artillery to have
it hit both of those guys these two yeah
oh this one ya know cuz you can only
move one spot so what I'm gonna do I
think I'm gonna knock Oh check this out
check-in it out BAM Zoe wanna move him
no I'm gonna try this first
dang it
oh yeah sick sick okay uh I can still
with me
no I can't that's the end wait who can
who still has an action oh this dude Oh
check this out
yeah oh oh we leveled up yeah sold
promotion so if you get if you kill
effort if you clear the map at any point
they like they tell you oh sick job oh
yeah attack that that oh I didn't clean
the matter still that still alright cool
so absolutely zero aside for my Mex take
a little damage but that repairs between
Rob so Ralph got promoted good ol Ralph
my powers doing fine I have to
reputation is not the best Oh so plus 3
grid defense um that increases the
chances the percentage of the buildings
not taking yeah alright what do I want
reputation right my power is fine
colonial Park are forgotten hills defend
the tanks I'll do the tanks I'll make up
for the fact that I didn't know I could
use them so I can well someone was
saying you had to protect them to then
like yeah maybe I just can't move I
don't know we'll figure it out I'm just
gonna do the same thing that worked out
well last time is gonna make a wall well
we got tricks
we'll see well either way yeah
I'm still poor sign like this is the far
the stuff I could have attacked me well
what's up ass off fo TV hello I'm glad
you're having fun watching us to play
this game well it's mainly my playing
Ohana you Te'o Hana Ohana Jasper 200
tanks I don't think I can I don't I
don't defend the tanks I don't ass off
OTP he's coming out tomorrow not came
into there he's gonna block and die he's
gonna die in two Mis hit this deal a
little bit
come on tank do something ooh
I'm not gonna block that I still kill
him he's still gonna get hit [ __ ] hon do
do I need are you kid yeah I'll reset
the turn because I don't want to lose
the tank okay
sorry guys let's figure this out I wish
the tanks could shoot I don't know why I
can't maybe I don't know okay um so what
I want to do move him first well that
makes sense does that make sense cuz I
there pretty much know so apparently now
I guess if they get killed before they
act they're active they die so maybe you
have to just like okay stall long enough
for the yeah used I don't know we'll
find out thanks jack nova or jec no I'm
still gonna hit him unless I move him
into the way well then you're gonna take
to damage that right no I think I can
kill oh wait good call
I don't want these buildings to get hit
for sure I'm trying to figure out what
to do with him I mean I guess I'll just
take two damage
block it this Dupin coming up and then
block it with Ralph to you I didn't have
to block with him
I mean punt well you wanted to punch
that guy in - yeah so he'll block that
and then you're taking two new damage
that's fine
maybe I'll get the tanks next turn if I
stood right would have been nice to have
that heal right now shoot those rocks
good dummy yeah Paula jeez from making
bad okay sweet that was good that was
good oh cool that's two excellent ok so
if the tank did take two right yeah okay
that's right I did but I mean you also
took out two okay sweet it looks like
[ __ ]
defended tanks I don't know
blaze Fang we are playing into the
breach it's a game by the FTL developers
coming out tomorrow you get to it's like
a tactical turn-based game where you're
kind of controlling these different
types of mechs of which we're hopefully
gonna get some more soon and you pretty
much try to you know complete the
objectives or bonus objective objectives
and bonus objectives damn it I don't
know if that's good or no they're still
gonna take a damage huh can I undo that
yeah yeah okay I got so he'll block
he'll take one but I can now that my
tanks not gonna take damage
so I'll knock him away previously he
would have hit me and blown up gotcha
so I want to just block as much as
possible I'm gonna box this dude in
that'll be fun next okay I do anything
so the mech can I even do anything I
don't have my - punch no I'm just gonna
block no he's got full health that's
good pronouncing what Jack no vote was
right I thought it was Jake could have
been Jay ooh
it was the same block dynami nice other
box in the box Hank's in danger
[ __ ] so I can't knock him this way he's
gonna hit the building can you push him
into the fire will that kill him I don't
think I can move anybody fire enough
over there - but I
except for Ralph yeah wreck-it Ralph oh
no you know what I could do okay I can
knock him once with Ralph once with the
tank but what about the buffer guy I
don't know he's gonna get bottled too
damn this is not good okay sweet tank
sir there we go six so boom get out of
here
so the tanks fine I also worry about the
student okay so he's because he only
attacked one tile and you can use the
tank they hit the buffer guy too later
if you need to yes I can move him first
to which would probably be helpful so
him I just got to put him on my mind for
now
that dudes a problem cuz he's gonna hit
my artillery which will blow it up which
is not game ending but I don't like it
so where can I move him he's not Webb so
he can move you know I'm gonna do this
give my other tank some room what them
oh they just push they don't actually
damage GG undo we can't no that's fine
that's unfortunate that they don't do
like one damage I'm gonna lose my
artillery pilot I think but that's fine
[Music]
unless I'm missing something and I guess
I'll just do that and Oh sick yeah could
you punch him now now that my
artilleries gonna die no matter what I
think
am I better off just letting him take
the now do this this is more fun I'll
kill him
well you could have killed him to begin
with without using your tanks shot no
because my tank was there he was here
before I show you have he has to be out
of the way yeah well my artilleries do
it no don't want to sacrifice himself to
get some damage I mean it's better than
him doing nothing if you know he's gonna
die right image yeah whatever
so he'll do took some damage he's gonna
block it still all right two turns so I
lost my artillery pallet but he wasn't
Ralph we love Ralph
my thanks fine he's gonna miss he's just
gonna hit the empty Mac oh six oh my
that it was worth it yes worth burn well
he burned out there since he's on fire
yes okay I think that's good so final
turn so he'll yeah he's dead don't have
to worry about him these two however
yeah well he's gonna die from Ross punch
right I think he won yeah so he took one
as well he's not attacking
he's gonna die he can push him another
way too
yep don't I try to kill him yeah what
else is going on yeah the only thing is
that that might do two damage because
you're gonna push them into the into the
mountain right oh yeah sweet you get
more experience yeah I mean like it's
like one of those you might as well and
that you know you push them off the map
but tanks don't do damage they push can
you push them off the map though no damn
that's just like opening ring out I
might as well go up here though hit him
take that gotcha all right pilot better
than you still defended the tanks and
got to reputation as men okay we're
going up onto a boss oh nice round
yeah and I really like the second squad
I get better but I like these the boxing
mech so Ralph is max level now I got to
see if I can upgrade Oh
Ori it's good knowing you ok do I have
any yeah things I can upgrade he's got a
Titan fist one man +1 reactor ok we need
to find a power oh this I gotta do one
more before I do the uh I'll try to
hurry through so I'll take less than
three did great damage protect the coal
plant what's this one defend this
satellite launches that's easier I'll do
this so I have ensure that I get I would
have to suck up suck pretty bad I think
to lose but let's not jinx it I just did
I think you did so he's got to defend
these satellite launches I don't know
which one's gonna launch first does it
tell me no so that they take like two
turns to launch each so for total turns
I think my last turn I can just try to
kill everybody
uh yes Waylon X this is on PC but not
till tomorrow I'll comes out tomorrow
the 27th ooh a pod mm-hmm that's what we
need
it'll be on Steam as well as GOG [ __ ]
sorry what happened everybody's
attacking something I gotta think this
one through so I don't want him to
attack ok so here's one way to do its
have my neck my tank takes some dommage
well I'm gonna knock came all the way so
he'll take that damage that's fine for
now
Ralph kill that guy straight up
yo you're right yeah and then I can move
my artillery to get that oh yeah hot pod
and he'll be in a good position to
unless I'm getting fans I'm gonna leave
the pod for now I don't you take a
damage though no you might be right so
just take that no he's gonna take damage
anyway yeah but not a big - yeah you
gotta I was gonna try to push him on to
the spa no you're right I'll just go for
the pod can I do anything now like can
you now they can enforce finally we're
good
would be nice to take a man died to save
the tank from taking a hit but oh yeah
[ __ ] I could no I still no right no I
could I don't think I could have moved
here that would be yeah no you're right
I could have gone here I thinking
it's oh no he would have shot the
building that was a ranged attack it's
by it all played out the same what I
don't want to do is knock anything in
b-cells so this one's about to launch
that's why it's red it's got the skulls
of it does it oh yeah yeah oh so oh
it'll kill anybody their interest
someday okay so he's ranged okay you can
kill that guy these two are problematic
is that right who and he's on fire he's
on fire excellent and then yeah Ralph's
gonna take that guy out I hope that's
right right that I owe that you tell me
I I don't know I've done this my guess
is it seems that way but even if he
doesn't he's attacking the wrong way
anyways right so I think you're fine no
I don't want to knock him out of fire oh
that's problem that I might I thought
there just lit on fire though cuz
remember that other guy was like lit up
on fire I guess it depends No yes
pecking no I'll push him out of it he
won't actually I'm you're right I don't
know but I don't I don't think I wanna
block at this because if I push this do
down he'll still hit the buildings mmm
unless can I knock him into will that
kill him no I think only one don't kill
one of them LS he gets a lit up on fire
- no should we try it or should I got a
reset reset turn try it I like it
no he's not on fire son of a I'll reset
because I could do this I could just
take a little damage with my artillery
artillery pilot is not a priority
because that's the AI yeah so what did I
do
you did that - what could I have done
that better the tank maybe I don't think
so I mean unless you're pushing the bug
from yet to push the bug down in - yeah
but if you push them down and would have
stopped him from going
it would have blocked another guy from
coming right well now you're definitely
walking I'll check this out I'll just
push him over okay good
there you go he's gonna die and then
we're on the assumption that the yeah
that's hope but the people Astor's do it
Mel
to do it well like I said even if it
didn't you would have been fine because
he was gonna with yeah all right all
right no just use yourself it does to
damage okay cool
oh it's - yes - here's that one anyway
though right okay
yeah scoop Mike is back let me so the
fire could help me out but now there's a
buff yeah but if you push him into the
fire he's dead right yeah I also want to
worry about this dude though right well
is how much alive does that guy have I
have record how much left is a scorpion
guy lookin dude have OS well with wha
I'm so he'll die if I yeah I on the next
turn but Ralph can't kill him but you
can push him out of the way with Ralph
if Ralph can get vertical to him I could
just go here now right here you mean no
if Ralph goes over where you yeah where
can i push him down I can yeah yeah and
then yeah whatever the best bet I might
as well just like try to decrease any
possible actually with Ralph
but oh no he wouldn't have been like oh
that's good oh yeah block mmm and he'd
be better I can well actually Ralph is
just gonna should have killed that guy
the the buffer right so I should undo
that for now good at all so now I can
kill this dude right hope so
no or push him away and push damn it
Ralph's gonna take some damage that's
fine
we both are Oh both ooh yeah whatever
we're almost again
we're fine just gotta worry about them
I'm worried more about Ralph than my uh
my AI here always is that everybody's
about Ralph wreck-it Ralph Oh cricket
Ralph that makes sense he wrecks things
the artillery units range is pretty much
the entire map in any direction except
you can't attack in an adjacent tile so
oh he just went into the fire like an
idiot yep so he's on fire he's gonna
sign this kind of sucks though
no on the webbing yeah that's fine these
are all MIT these are all one space
attackers hmm so how do you live here
don't know
so he's got to health oh yeah he has web
to shoot man and those things have three
life right the Scorpion looking things I
think yeah so you can't kill him with
Ralph yeah this isn't that great
and also the exhaust is gonna come out
here next round so he's gonna he's not
gonna die I gotta do one more damage of
him yeah I can have Ralph survive he'll
take one that guy's toast again huh yeah
the artillery I'm just dying over and
over well at this point it's about it's
just like makes I hear the satellite guy
artillery will take the Ralph's oh [ __ ]
no that's guy that guys me like oh yeah
we're good good what's the last can I
even attack anything you could shoot the
guy oh here we go
that's not good killed though no yeah
push him forward into the fire oh [ __ ]
you're right but that's not Geico okay
we still do more damage than one right
yeah where's my artillery two more
damage down like I'm in the fire hill
I'll just do that it'll either way
you're right at all
I guess he will die and you'll get the
experience maybe probably from the burn
for the burnout
he doesn't fire damage he died that's
good or else in the artillery is gone
that's fine still yeah that's launching
I think we're good
do you get to do anything here nope nice
weak oh did you get that kill the burn
one I don't even know I didn't it would
have taken another turn alright cool so
now we're at the corporate HQ my powers
final we didn't we need power trying to
get to that next reactor core yeah
what's this fly over the target while
dropping smoke yes woah that's really
good cuz the smoke cancels any attack
they're about to do that's what the yes
in the second squad I just find that
animation hilarious editing just like
hopping over to space I'm like dropping
a fart on them it's like here you can't
see bro what just happened - I don't
know what just happened that's okay so
that's really good that's the basic
attack for one of the new squads there's
the smoke Mike it's smoke death
I don't know okay I'm in good shape I
like that attack and Nick fairies doing
all right he's got five more experience
to the next level up Ralph is all the
way up
nope I'll adjust the AI okay so now
there's seismic activity now you go back
to perform seismic activity now we got
boss destroy the Firefly leader it's
that purple one and protect the
corporate tower
oh it's purple what's up strays region
ass agar hello so I got a really good
attack with my tank now that literally
just canceled smoke is awesome in this
game like it's just like equipped it
right yep okay I sincerely hope I did so
look at his range oh jeez
he gets the whole if that's a rook yeah
anything yes so now you would probably
want to block it
oh that's too damn oh yeah the wah wah I
don't think the boss is too much water
and he's probably still gonna be he can
walk in water he's you can't attack
though in water so the BAM is a tax con
that's good I'll just straight-up block
that and kill this dude no okay yep and
just move him out no he'll hit the
building what can I do here artillery
just take the hit again I guess I didn't
think that one through
what is this range the entire map I
think yeah what's better pushing I'll
hit him I think hitting it was probably
better all right whatever
my artillery will take the hit once
again large oh that's only four turns
they're nowhere near the corporate tower
either and also artilleries
non-community that's fine Ralph can kill
that guy if we had 200 I'm just gonna
knock him into the water again yeah
don't say Oh or hmm it's the best thing
to do here don't know that's getting
spicy though you could push that guy in
the water right mmm yeah but with who
with the tank guy that we want Ralph to
push the boss no I'll move him on the
way I can knock him into the water then
I can knock the tank this dude into his
line of fire
hear me out well this is a boss okay man
the boss is gonna hit that guy
regardless though no yes you're right
but still I could do some damage
yeah it's up to you I don't want to kill
him his only thing or I do want to kill
him but not much
shot what else could I do right now
knock came into the water no cuz my tank
will take damage that's fine I'll move
here so he'll take okay yeah and it's
blocking Oh what are you gonna take
damage because is he gonna die from the
blocking before the boss shoots him cuz
he's your get is your tank gonna take
damage at all no he's attacking first
okay oh [ __ ] you're right
I might take damage that's fine not or I
could do this
push him BAM he's dead he's in the water
it's not attacking alright
there's no block but that's fine
whatever no I mean like as long as I'm
killing them I don't mind new ones
coming up oh [ __ ] oh the buff the buff
plus the tower
oh [ __ ] and I'm webbed okay I'm I think
I'm good
well you could kill the buff if you had
to what's the order of [ __ ] I can't
knock him with the tank he'll hit the do
I just want straight-up kill the buff
with what with who though well Ralph is
definitely got killed but then the tank
might need to take some damage I'm just
gonna kill him and Knauer Tillery push
that guy into the water maybe yes I
don't know if that's what you want to do
though oh that wasn't even the play I
was thinking abut great no I'm gonna
have the tank take one I'll kill this
yeah yeah that's oh I didn't even real
okay that's great that's even better
than what I always think yeah I'm not
doing too well on damaging the boss but
a certain point I could just screw up
only two more up coming up now sorry
Greg we that you can't play yet until
tomorrow but appreciate you tuning in
hanging out with me and Mike while we
get through hopefully this first boss
battle yeah good we just got a last one
more turn Mike one more turn again he's
not a problem but I want to kill the
boss if possible do you get more stuff
for it mm-hmm I got a reputation point
to spend on stuff do enough damage he's
got five cuz I can knock him into him
he's gonna attack first well like that
won't kill him though I don't think well
how much damage you know more holy [ __ ]
I'm gonna let the boss kill his buddy
cuz he does 4 damage nice so I'll kill
him I'll just do the same thing here
kill him nice from down to ooh
achievement chief a watery grave sweet
so now what do I want to do anything
with the tank no because you want the
boss to kill him right can you kill that
guy with the tank not really right at
least no you don't smoke them I could
smoke him no yeah okay just to show you
what it's like I'll smoke this smoke
that yeah so then you protect the
building right poop on him you're
protecting the building the boss oh the
boss would kill them anyway but whatever
that was more fun to watch so the smoke
cancel attack boom that's so dope okay
he's dead damn he's dead no yeah well we
didn't get a rep point I got one of them
corporate didn't take any damage
corporate yeah corporate HQ man got to
protect Quentin says this reminds me of
advanced war and that his girlfriend is
a super fan of the movie Pacific Rim
well lucky for her and you because isn't
Pacific room two coming on and like a
couple months I think so yeah it's like
sooner than I think I got a lot of
reputation actually sevens not bad okay
let's see what we want to buy Lou look
at all they're all we have equipped so I
can't donate some of this to get more
impatient I don't think okay prime class
for my Oh what was that move deal for
Dan we're damage and I'm gonna get that
do that I'll get back to him and it's on
sale what's that thing on sale sorry
freeze yourself and nearby tiles yeah oh
is that like a one-time when you use
kind of thing you probably I'm not I
don't know if I'm ready to save that you
can do some sacrificial impassive
I don't need power right what's the pass
all pilots survived death day that's a
passive - I'll do that you only got
three points left just drop smoke on
five tiles anywhere on the map well
smoke bum tactical strike that's super
good I'm gonna do that you know what
though I didn't even get a Power Core
can you undo oh we got no that's a tank
one oh yeah it's like so I know so this
is a passive one of them that's passive
that'll just happen yeah but we paid so
much more for they're only giving us
half that fights back I still got one
more do I haven't yeah I've got one
of that I'll get no one to save it for a
cord next time no it's only for this
island
oh really I'm okay well maybe right
actually it's too late now
but no I can just donate it back no if
you donate it back it's not worth as
much as when you paid well that was one
reputation okay whatever so now alright
so you get a new squad maybe go to this
island then we'll I don't think I don't
know if I can new CEO Jessica Kern yeah
these people are about protect corporate
my advisers insist we're losing the
fight they also insist I trust you and
since those cowards rarely insist I do
anything I'm giving you a chance to
prove yourselves sounds good powers not
looking too bad do I have where is the
rust crew man the rusting Hulk's I got
it
I think I might need one more coin
because I have one from the puddle water
and I think I beat them the island so I
should have it let me let me I'll try to
go all out and see if I could die and
then uh no no we don't want you to die
why would you die what can I know I can
use the freeze yourself what having that
smoke thing I think I just strike back
the right thing oh oh oh it's not even
it doesn't it's just a one-time use okay
who should I give it to you though no
he's got the smoke jump does it take a
does it take up like a turn no it's just
extra thing mercury fist oh that's what
I want to give him if possible I need to
though oh no I got it boom he's got
mercury fist okay sweet the passive
though can I get that anybody know
pilots died what's more valuable to
smoke I think I think if you play right
the smokes probably better yeah okay
sweet we got a lot of upgrades there
actually oh and here's another reactor
core I'll do this alright even the earth
mover and protect the Defense lab we're
in a new area all right so the deserts
where is the [ __ ] danger good question
I guess that would be Ralph that's the
closest thing we got to a [ __ ] danger
right now what is that from that's from
Pacific Rim oh I think the [ __ ] danger
is the is that them Thank You prime
Charlie Charlie Hunnam yeah is that the
primary one or is that the one see I
might have to use that smoke right away
yeah that's the primary align the [ __ ]
danger so they're right up against
whatever this thing
I'm defending the earth mover oh is that
tremor that earthquake that like this
this whole island like terraform stuff
so like stuff will shift is the buff
different because these orange is that
just like environmental aesthetic um so
that's the earth mover I want to defend
that hit him can I kill him
nothing reminds me of the thing in Metal
Gear survived hmm don't use the smoke
yet or can I survive without it let me
so he's attacking him that's fine I just
move I'm gonna block him Oh what should
I use this thing is it one time used
though I don't know what's that other
thing that new that beetle looking thing
yes they jump over stuff so he's going
in there he's fine
I'll use my smash kill him knock him
over sweet that was dope hurt you too
though or was that from the I've no clue
actually that looked like you got hurt I
guess we don't have known that okay
gonna take another damage so just be
careful at Ralph later cuz you're gonna
be on like one life alright guys won't
kill the buff right
he's gonna go sweet uh okay okay he's
gonna take old leave smoke behind - yeah
I guess so
that's pretty cool unless that was the
beetle I hit I know I might have uh no
no that's fine it doesn't do anything
yeah yeah that's fine
earth mover oh that's not so fine though
and you got something crawling under you
yep I gotta knock him out of the way and
and move right yes dad yeah it's the me
one that gets rekt yeah it's true he'll
jump there now it's not gonna kill him
but I'd like to and then damn it
how do you protect your buildings I'll
kill this dude hit him there ah
cuz then he's gonna take I was gonna die
reset turn that's like it never happened
yeah I do something wrong with the tank
maybe your oh my god I got it
yeah cuz then you don't if you don't
push the beetle but is the the beetle is
gonna hit that one building those I
don't have to deal with them later
yeah no I can go here no I'm just saying
isn't that guy gonna or no if I if I hit
him
Oh knock him back our health land here
no cuz then I have to yeah I'll kill him
with it the time for a tactical strike
[ __ ] okay they resisted well I got luck
of the draw 18% chance no problem oh my
god
talk about okay the good things I got
bad lifestyle right here dang you're
gonna have four months there's a deal
with here yeah they're all bunched up
and I got that smoke attack and his
smoke attack and I can't use his thing
again there's one time use and it would
kill me
so it's just terraform it's that guy's
got a lot of life five life for that one
yeah that one dude yeah it's got a knock
in a way this does look bad I agree
things are getting spicy like I'm just
gonna I think the best thing is to knock
him into him that won't kill me I'll
kill him Moke oh it's only five squares
like that but I could do it anywhere in
the map so I got a piece I was thinking
about it I was thinking maybe over there
cuz it sounds like it looks like you're
gonna deal with the other side more oh I
don't know that one Beatle is gonna hit
me building this now you're right last
some of I'll push him into the water
yeah I think this is my best thing but I
don't think I can use that after it or
whatever will do I doubt he'll hit him
yeah water will suffice thanks Jessica
man he's still gonna hit that thing now
I don't wanted to do that there's two
people hitting that damn it
the reset has been used um oh he's gonna
jump there - wait you got smoke on that
guy though
the other guy yeah you could drop a yeah
but yeah do I defend that I'll defend
the earth more for the reputation you
just have to protect the defense lab and
the earth mover where's the defense
lever that's the lab you definitely want
the lab because that's an electric or
the smoke right there is blocking a
can't you smell guys let them knock him
out of the way well at least I block
them from coming up okay I do with him
though he's gonna - and blow that up the
son of a-- I I think I screwed up
hopefully oh that guy is dead yeah
earthmovers going it's not it's just
reputation so I mean I think the defense
lab is more important here Oh from 84 so
no problem 18% sweet that was the Jack
Nova we don't have the he'll item
anymore unfortunately that thing is
toast was last place at home oh but you
can push him in the water right unless
this guy massive is he a massive that
resists let me think this through
I'll push him with him yeah 5 XP is he
gonna die though this guy oh I guess
that you're pushing him out of the way
anyways I just gotta knock him first
Hill in there knock him in a smoke and
just hurt him in daddy's dead yeah we're
good so that's it so we didn't get the
reputation but we're gonna get that
we're gonna get that reactor core which
is probably more important yeah a point
cuz I can rank up somebody's movement or
something good it went worse we got we
got real lucky - 18 % resists I a geek
topia the you can so it I keep
forgetting but if I was to move my if I
was to use the wrench yeah I can repair
1 point per turn I just can't attack
with that mech I just haven't been doing
it because yeah I noticed that too I've
been overwhelmed by vex so much that
usually just best to sacrifice one or
maybe not it's just that's my take on it
ok so I got one reactor core I can
increase his move
this smoke bomb has moved oh I can
increase this no I can't any - whew
that's really good I like that so now I
can hit buildings and it won't do a
damage push them away that's dope
I don't know how that's I know right
five whole but how do you huh yeah so we
made some new new turret bullets they
can actually hit buildings but they
don't actually hurt the buildings they
kind of like push everything away though
you know I got kinetic blast I don't
think any power I think I'm just going
to defend the Train yeah I think you're
gonna sighs make activities cool
okay well that's up to you as I say you
don't really need power because you've
been doing a pretty good well we've also
gotten lucky and realistic if we're I'm
being honest here we really got lucky
laughs do they die if they get in the
way of the train or does the train get
messed up oh man let me look at this it
does smash the ground dealing huge
damage and pushing adjacent tiles
doesn't look like why did it hurt him I
don't know I'll figure it out this time
okay so I'm just gonna block everything
with them get them up close so sorry you
said we had to beat this map okay
there's no planet so next playthrough I
could start on this plane it wouldn't be
as hard now so he's blocking train what
a jerk all there goes that I don't think
the whole oh that's good actually that's
gonna be a great thing you got a block
stop it from damaging and I worked by
the buff so yeah he's gonna move there
oh [ __ ] though these two will be
completely blocked by the train next
turn so I might have to get someone in
there
ooh so this doesn't hurt build it up
damn it
yeah so push him into the thing Shh
douche I don't get out of that that
right well if you do this if you get
Hannah he's not gonna die though right
isn't it either way is the same except
that if you do the push it hurts them
both
where did oh no they hurt some book
because of artillery okay he's gonna get
messed up
he'll die from the dude coming up punch
this jerk okay yeah no damage taken good
the Train is safe he's dead he's gonna
die
she's gonna whiff go well that's a fast
train he's dead enemy he's blocked oh
and what it might have been a volatile
Veck that blow up defend the train just
okay what is a kit so that the guy blew
up yeah so then it hurt the Train and
then it also killed the other guy so
there goes that reset turn reset turn I
wanna reset so you can get the two stars
back for the defending the train the
train train got messed up yeah the Train
is now dead dude I can't no go back in
time to start the current turn and now
it's defend the damaged train so you get
one star instead of two oh [ __ ] okay
what am i thanks Victor boys says the
awesome channel thanks for coming by and
thanks for the kind words appreciate it
okay so the train doesn't block me but I
can block oh oh geez I'm sorry if I
butchered name a goon goon æther I'm
just gonna say glue third Luther Jurgis
in says the orange flying jellyfish
kaiju makes all the others explode on
death good to know okay thank you cuz
yeah so that's the orange no later first
names I might have been happening
yesterday I just didn't know what the
best thing to do with him go here you
don't want that guy to damage to train
the the beetle [ __ ] can't do anything
about it huh no sorry well technically
you could you could for damage him but
it's probably not worth it your super
punch no I don't I can't I'm not I can't
go but well then
nope I'll just let the train get messed
up side objectives game over sorry oh
there goes all civilians but I'm still I
didn't lose any power at least like
because I have I guess I guess that's
true I guess you're only it's only this
side objectives so as long as you're not
losing the main game that it's all good
I guess these beetles are annoying yeah
but you're gonna push him out of the way
right so
oh you could totally do the the building
thing oh that works too oh yeah good I
just do this thought it'd be cool to
watch us blow up the fake attempt to
shoot the building and then have it push
it away it's over it's over it's fine we
didn't the Train sorry to the people on
the train trying to scale I almost kill
everyone too though yeah whatever
so no reputation still secured the
reason though I'm every maglev we lose
we lose two cities shut up hey we still
protected a thousand people's like what
do you guys want oh oh higher threat
though terraformers cool well we're
getting it pretty far in display there
so I'll do a hard one anyway um okay
what's easy whoa [ __ ] sorry it's cool
coffee still good
not that much luckily it's long enough
this keyboard up off that so here why
don't you keep going I'll just grab a
paper towel I don't think it's going no
that's fine don't worry about pretty
contained here yeah it's free contained
okay cool
so the terraformers cool in a neater I
got killed the buff dude first that
guy's exploder yeah I don't even know if
he gives the buff or does he flying
units came over all other vekl explode
on death yeah
dealing I should start looking at these
little tutorial things
protip so he's fine the terraformer is
pretty cool I need like six squares and
one direction will turn to desert and
that's also terraform the grass line
back to desert is an objective as well
so what I want to do with these guys get
my macro right up in the fray get the
tank up on these beetles and get my
artillery ready at long-range I guess
alright so the terraformers destroys
anything within those rows blocks the
six blocks in any direction yeah
[ __ ] so will it matter if they blow up
I'm just careful that one guy's inch so
I can go here and then I'll do those six
obviously don't wanna do that that's
probably the best are you sure it's a
kill it is yeah yesterday um I want to
make sure that that you know that so
that's four I have to do each direction
once a turn so I had you there yeah
that's gonna get you two of your grassy
field let's do that
and kill them nice geez so I only oh
there's a lot of smoke that's good too
except for me if I'm trying to okay I'm
gonna the beetle at the bottom it's
gonna hit the terraform yeah well you
can kill the buff guy with Ralph which
is good and probably push that guy off
or but you probably wanna push them off
into a square that you're gonna tear for
him you're right yeah oh this I will
tariff on the square but he'll the tank
will take damage but that's fine which
has more tank yeah I'll do this yeah cuz
you're gonna end up doing those bottom
six squares most likely right here
yeah the tangle take damage but or no
well the smoke cancel it by the time he
gets there it might oh that's pretty
that was tactical right you you planned
that all oh you could still me okay I'll
shoot him I guess don't kill him but
can't hurt to I'm last
no excite have an attack why you're
gonna get it right in his face
no oh I was like you crazy it doesn't
matter how much damage terraform will
destroy him um trying to get anything
else I could do
smoke attack no I used these dudes
things
he's got three health he's fine
kids smoke them if you really want to
but you know I did get right next to him
oh really because I can't do that oh
that's a jumping one my bad I thought
that was the tactic now that's the
Hillary doing okay
well hopefully the smoke three layers of
smoke right through it Katrina layers
oh you guys so lucky though you guys
feel lucky that you're resist it oh and
he's in a bad spot now which is like
yeah hey should hide yeah I forgot
that's my bad actually saw that it did
three damage anything
so wait here's one thing can they come
up through terraformed land
I wonder or do I just kill this dude go
this way first now man I could kill that
no I gotta do this now let me think this
through so I can we're at a very big
disadvantage right now cuz I can't go
there and kill in two fires there hi
Bryan week this is into the breach it's
a new game that's coming out tomorrow
made by the same developers of FTL we
just lost our tank does that work though
or is that just a terraform no that's
just a terraform I think I'm just gonna
move them out here and do these squares
Oh get rid of that thing we gotta worry
about this dude how do I get I don't i
think this do might take damage or he
might do some damage to the buildings
damn I don't want to want to get on fire
and I'll just that wouldn't help well
you're trying to terraform that guy
right he said I guess yeah but I also
have this dude to worry about this is
tough so what do I do with him like
that's fire I'll let him go on fire not
came into there his attacks cancelled
those building will take damage but I'll
just get him out of here
block gonna take a damage yep okay
anyway is there a better place I can
move with him either way I'll just take
the fire damage and move out of there
anyway he's gonna miss you thinks gonna
get terraformed oh yeah oh cool here we
go cancel his attack save the buildings
right yeah there we go and now terraform
this s so busy okay so I'm on track to
defend the territory terraformer and
terraform coal plants fine my max can I
take one damage but that's I don't know
a necessary sacrifice fire damn it it's
fine only one dude came up don't - did
okay I just gotta get Ralph out of there
oh I'm gonna tear form down here though
or which way should I - alright Ralph
let's get you out of here just kill this
dude that should be fine he's I think
he's gonna be off of fire if that makes
sense what are you gonna do with this
guy there's two guys there's one guy
that's gonna hit the turf or you can
terraform you can terraform that yeah
and then you can kill that other guy I
can put that over voice my artillery and
knock him away to save the buildings I
want to do that or save my artillery I
think either way oh wait no you could
yeah so you could potentially block and
then block is you know I should have
known I should have removed no I
wouldn't be able to hit him so move him
here he blocks this dude and then you
guys just shoot but ya can just knock
him over and
is there any other way to do this I
don't know man kill him I'm just
starting to just think how does a ralph
live actually you know what yeah I'm
gonna let the building's take one hit
I've got a decent amount of power I'm
gonna kill him what the buildings take
that hit who knows maybe this 18%
another 18% just like resist oh [ __ ] why
is he still on fire
you better repair him he'll a power
that's power from that right all oh no I
could terraform him I see and he's dead
oh honey no artillery go cuz he blocked
oh [ __ ] do you have to repair here and
terraform but there's a terraformer oh
it's gonna die in one hit right yeah no
Ralphs is the number one priority here
man
you gotta save Ralph how are those
repairing I guess so remove fire ice
yeah [ __ ] so you lose a terraformer but
Ralph lives
what's up moving though okay I'm gonna
tear from the land I'll get you'll get
the other two bonuses no right yes
protect the coal plant yeah you're gonna
get two out of the three and Ralph lives
unless you go all-in no do you think
he'll okay i from fire yeah do you think
he'll die if I complete the map
no yeah yeah I'll he'll be fine cuz it
would have to start my next turn I don't
have another turn does he die in two
hits here though he doesn't die in a -
yeah but I knock him into the out of
there and he doesn't hit the terraformer
I get that I get all three objectives
watch okay so he's gonna attack Oh what
I thought all that should have in the
beginning of my alright whatever
mission complete everyone's dead
whatever I got Ralph Ralph paid the
price Oh time to go to time travel so
now what they're all AI I wish I could
tell how many coins I had oh it's humans
here we go
[Music]
hashtag ralph is dead man you can't
abandon no I'm tryin cuz I want to show
you other max I don't know if I can yet
though let me try to beat this island oh
sorry how much time with corporate HQ
right can't you do HQ different wait for
the size again so I did three I think it
need to do one more what time we're
running out of time but like fast I'm
down I'm down to lies earthquake so this
is this become chasms killing any ground
unit president okay I'm just gonna all
right dude he's building that shield
this looks easy and that's why it's only
lesson three great damage I'd have to
really suck to not get this bonus
objective in a pod it feels bad yeah
feels bad do the mechs still have those
upgrades is my question
it wasn't yeah the mechs will they won't
on the next playthrough but they do
right now you know I mean yeah I think
know what that was what happened it was
Oh cuz there's no hide the Ralph yeah
Ralph had that bonus but these two still
have it okay um to this guy I don't like
these guys he explode he's remember he
makes everything explode here's my
question
yeah all take damage though no cuz he'll
die they want
yeah they don't explode I'd first guy oh
because he didn't die the other guys
died before him when he was still active
yeah he's just gonna miss go for it no
whoops I'd knock him over smoke him
don't know I could jump over two targets
yeah wish I knew that that's pretty dope
is this uneasy no it's not normal
commitment issues I see I see I see that
name oh you know I'm gonna do check this
[ __ ] out okay
checking it out push everyone knock up
him and push those dudes now I can kill
him water the walk oh forgot about that
- oh [ __ ] okay you better get that pod
oh are you gonna die though trying to
get the pod yeah
is it worth the Potter I think so cuz
raus not in there anymore right
I don't know you should just use
exceedance at this point you're just
trying to hope but then it's gonna make
the last part harder to right yeah I
don't know if I could certainly can I
survive two turns with just these so
he's gonna die do you think I could
survive these last two days just
artillery man I don't know maybe it's
gonna fly into the water if I move
because we're up how that works I'm
pretty sure we're gonna knock him are
you sure that's not just a ranged attack
no it's a beetles oh yeah you're right
I think he just shoots that far right I
want I wish I knew it was in the pot but
can't you reset turn after I didn't tell
you till after the attack order I don't
think matters right now
because he's gonna miss he's gonna fly
by him can I knock him off it won't
matter he's gonna die next day anyway
and now it knock him into him go
sacrifice him for I don't know I mean I
think I could do it I'm gonna take the
rest all right it was worth it was worth
good knowing you AI companion what do I
do here knock him into it's only two
more turns - by the way so I don't think
it's too bad might as well just kill him
well I can't I would love if he just
flew in but yeah I think yeah maybe
maybe that combat medic is like a
titanfall American fly he's dead sorry
use your ultimate No
all right yeah yeah what's just arena
stacking so he's gonna jump and miss
know his range - he's artillery he drop
smoke - which is interesting
oh they're all gonna die there if they
just stay there yeah but they they can
move still great this is great
they're all folk sep for that guy that's
fine yeah but I only have to worry about
yeah yeah yeah and he's gonna die in one
shot and they have shields anyway so
you're not gonna be able to push that
guy far enough though but that has
shields anyway oh dude do the artillery
thing and push him off and then have the
tank kill that beetle dude oh yeah
assuming he has that move still Oh
cuz this whole rows gonna disappear
right I know what you're talking about
yeah so like yeah zero yeah but I gotta
move I got to do him first
because I know so you're gonna kill him
yeah they're all gonna die from the
platform disappearing and then we got
the cool non-city damage I don't even
think I needed that as it has a shield
yeah but I mean that still makes the
shield intact okay sweet the the friend
got him all the five an axe sacrifice
come on man we got the pot now and now I
get that same mech back nothing lost
Ralph's still dead rest in peace that's
how you do it greed plays protect it
every civilian showing off gameplay
massif it was worth it it's not bad cuz
I mean okay here we go
okay I'm gonna do the last corporate HQ
I'll hurry through these what do I want
to equip plus one move my artillery what
can I do plus one range for the smoke
bombs what does that do like increase
potential moving rates by one you can
jump three squares is that what that
doesn't show it though so I would not I
would not its to health oh [ __ ] let's do
help for that I might do that oh that's
pretty good especially yeah that's a
nice that's a nice a little it makes
sense oh he could do it on any one of
them you could have did the know his oh
you're totally right actually would make
sense to not do it on the artillery
right it makes sense to do on the prime
yeah but he's so weak now way to go
yeah but he's yeah but he's you know
he's in the fritz cuz I just don't have
it powered I could just power that now
but do it like that
all pilots survived at all my don't have
any pilots alive freeze yourself should
I try that just for fun I want you to
beat them oh you can't do it anyways not
about power I want you to beat the
mission so that we can kind of get to
the next Island okay I mean oh here we
go
purple purple beetle here got to protect
corporate we'll just make a wall so he's
the boss I wanna I don't even know if I
care about taking up just right wolf
being a jerk you know immediately
okay what's mine what's my play here
he's melee who's the boss melee looks
like it right no he does oh no he's the
scorpion he does two in every direction
yeah we can push them away
corporate I gotta move em back to tho
shoot corporate tell them the oh you're
right shoot corporate to push him away
yeah but I'm trying to figure out I
could that's gonna push your guy though
but do I want to go up and do some
damage to him first
I'm just trying to push him back right
now oh you know what boom and he's gonna
kill everything yeah yeah yeah nice well
played
get out of here tactical yeah thanks
yeah thanks idiot killed your buddies so
sweet he's still I'm gonna try he'd be
using him yeah I do damage him 1 or 2
- it was kill him this time I don't know
I think he did too
but you could push him again with
artillery into blocking the hole and
killing the beetle damn this
disabilities is pretty sick yeah ah [ __ ]
reset yeah cocky ok I gotta move him
first and then I could do that he's not
even a problem I'm just gonna let him
die you could push him under the what if
there's two of them one of the things it
does it stop it from getting pushed and
we're okay that sucks I'm gonna move him
back and shoot him yeah and then I just
punch this dude with anything if you
shoot him then he's not gonna take the
two from the scorpion
right but it's too late now it's fine
whatever daddy here at least it's gonna
block though or you could push him over
to hit the beetle if you want I already
used this no no what the oh but he's
he's netted right now yeah yeah I'm not
going away yeah all right well you're
still fine yeah dang it that would help
take out his beetle he's got how many
health left three two three one guys
coming up here so yeah oh you're gonna
take some and blocked yeah Wow it's
gonna take someone no you can push him
with the tank right and you'd be fine
[ __ ] man
it's okay two turns I know I'm a problem
and I gotta figure out what I need
pushing with the tank that is very bad
yeah but I have to write or smoke him
what pushing me better or smokey just
cancelling it the pack all you want to
kill him yeah hopefully kill him rather
and you can push that he doesn't have
the attack anyway you can push that guy
in the water yes
you wanted to sorry sorry my back's good
but does this sleep smoke you know what
I could do how I wonder what his range
would be if I use the smoke on these two
because I'm gonna have to take building
damage I think Oh from that one either
him or him yeah I think that's fine if
you can get the you can still do what
you need to oh [ __ ] is it three damage
though yes are they both three yes none
of them are gonna attack corporate we
don't want to do the tank
maybe they'll resist that 15% I have a
Ralph anymore for that extra three I
would say kill him or you definitely
have to stop one of the two right no I
have this it's like we knew or you knew
there we go sweet oh we're good we are
Gucci and we should be able to kill this
guy hopefully we just walk up to him
these tiles he's only got three life
left so Ralph and someone else would be
an Oh corporate corporate is now in
danger I think I can kill him
well you could also have Ralph and maybe
the tank kill the Scorpion and then how
the artillery pushed him away
I don't know if that's melee if that
guy's melee though him know if that guy
is in melee you could have the artillery
potentially push him away and then it
can the tank and Ralph's kill tillery's
webbed right now oh so he can move he's
just gonna go that way oh he's too far
to for Ralph - OH can you have the tank
yes push them down a squared so that
Ralph can get to here take one Jim if
Ralph's there can get the shootings the
rule yeah I can't shoot through if
that's what you meant yeah yeah okay
then that's not gonna work so you're not
gonna be able to kill him this turn
which is means you can't kill him in
general I don't think I just need to do
webbing him would help a lot but I don't
know what I can cuz if Ralph goes in the
smoke are you affected by the smoke in
the same way yeah hack I think I need to
do this protect corporate yeah but the
artillery guy could protect corporate to
you by pushing him away he's gonna do
how many dams to blow it's fine it's an
AI he'll hit him I was just trying to
find a way to kill the scorpion but I
don't think we can which is unfortunate
no you do this though at least
you box him in I guess first no it
doesn't matter now it's the game is done
or the map is done oh damn no got both
we didn't just try the Scorpion oh right
okay my bad
now whatever Hey we could have killed
that scorpion I feel like yeah shoot
artillery corporate yeah that's my strat
man you just shoot corporate with an
artillery if you really are the last
hope for Humanity we don't stand a
chance
she's what a B what a B Z man reputation
was easy
fire nondamaging projectile that pushes
tiles around target jump forward and
push adjacent tiles away
what's that Gatling gun buildings gain a
shield after taking damage yeah but then
they still take damage yeah
the only thing you'd have to brute class
what's that
she projectile that I like that yeah to
damage an area oh damn it cyborg man
says I got a bunch of great power Eric
please play Rainbow six siege outbreak
on stream it's not out yet right it's
not out till the six on test servers
it's out oh yeah we played that on on
stream already then yeah I like it
smoker I like this better let me power
that just before I forget um leave
Island I think I should get the coin now
I hope you did yeah so I could you want
me to show this I own or go back and try
it okay so i unlock the island I can
start here anyway so I'm gonna ban its
playthrough just for the streams sake
okay watch your watch by the way it's
gonna get something off a so so now you
should hopefully have the other mix oh
yeah three o'clock okay so Bali uh-huh
really it's okay they each have a theme
so this one I like they take advantage
well you played them already
yeah and we've seen the smoke beam
technology and shield technology or this
is the duty mass destruction there's
around the mass destruction cape of
harness look at lightning or lasers
lightning okay yep you knew where my
heart lies yeah
oh he's got like got a bunch of like I
don't know like whips with electricity
yeah like whiplash so I could mix and
match but let just roll the new squad
and I'll start on the yo Ralph's back
ain't no thing oh [ __ ] wait what oh yeah
he was the bone he was the they just
went back to
so yeah you unlock other people but okay
cool so I'll start and I'll start from
the snow island it's scaled so you can
do that yeah you can do them in any
order once you unlock them it just
scales that's sitting on so probably be
our last map here but thank you all for
tuning in
do a hard one no I'll do it this one
just try to showcase the ice is cool
yeah you mean you could see the little
half tiles that you can destroy so they
break five buildings out of the ice kill
at least seven enemies no problem think
I break them out all right I don't know
what this dude is this is the prime one
he's the melee dude looks like this is
the tank I would imagine that's that's
um that's a bacillus there destroy
Boulder Mac we'll figure it out dude is
that like a harpoon it looks like hey
listen yeah he does have like electric
whips yeah dude he's gonna they're
called the Blitzkrieg that's
uncomfortable I mean what is the purple
buffer dude dude check it out all there
Veck have incoming weapon damage reduced
by one jeez that's pretty good that's
just the same thing how is he different
from the green ones cuz the green ones
give health alright this is like
reducing damage yeah I guess yeah
similar murmur as opposed to hell okay
what does this dude do let's see use a
grapple to pull max toward objects or
units to the max to the mech huh
that's what's a grappling oh he could
grapple himself to though to the away
from it what is this dude dude just
electric train damage look at that this
chain lightning baby alright considering
I don't we're not gonna get crazy far at
this plate I'm just gonna like go all
out right into the water
yeah so that's not gonna change anybody
but I'll still hit him only does one
that's but it does a owee if you're near
them I'd show two on the daying
contraband I get a tile pushing adjacent
tiles what does the rock survive it if
it's I wonder if the rock stays if it
doesn't hit anybody
I doubt it oh so you can create barriers
to oh it does okay li-an what can I do
with him grapple yourself to a rock and
free these villages oh yeah you're great
I want to be
doing his billings right oh my do things
course you get over me undo that
yeah whatever don't know what that just
looked cool yeah okay so this is that's
fine right we want them to hit it
building though I yes so they didn't
want sometimes their enemies frozen here
so they try to free their enemies you
could stop them or go ahead attack that
please please oh you want that guy don't
you a lot of AoE here I'm just gonna
keep my lighting dude right in the
middle of everything was it only in
front of you or how many squares
everything okay Oh two to this dude I
didn't only do Oh
so it only did one to that last guy
because he had the armor so normally
does - hmm oh and they yeah okay you
want those two toys now by the way you
do want them too yeah get over here save
him oh yeah go call he's in danger now
for the boulders that's pretty good
check this out that's pretty I can block
it I think oh oh no no no [ __ ]
reset okay what did I do okay I
lightning and then pulled him out yeah
you lightning then you pull them out but
the boulder move is legit though yeah I
like that and see that being oh man this
is cool guys want to hit him right or no
no no no you wanted to free the building
though right yeah but yeah good point
ROM okay do with this Boulder though
well I mean if you really wanted to you
could Boulder him into the hole but then
they don't want to pry someone won't
free up the building I don't know they
don't like for people to deal with oh
I'll take care of Billings yeah but you
want a OE baby alright yeah good point
actually yeah the crowds aren't as big
of a deal now um
what where do I want to put this rock
though I don't even need to attack
I don't know I'm liking this unit though
yeah I'll just keep them there for now
alright
Hilary your villages dude that's fine
thank you or two three
I gotta kill seven enemies though as
well so I gotta start mopping [ __ ] whoa
that's good you want him to free that
one yeah come up come up woohoo oh we
don't want that though damn I missed
that uh no building damage power already
just this right Oh that'll mess him up
that's fine that guy's not gonna hit
anyone oh you killed yeah what's he
doing
not even attacking can you kill with
that grappling hook guy or is he just oh
okay pull in the water that's no that's
not water's no no no it's not water oh
dude check this [ __ ] out
what do you think I could I think I
could break this do you think the water
will fall through the water
I mean Rock yeah well the rock fall
through the ice does that is that what
that means I don't know [ __ ] no that's
not gonna destroy completely don't do
that but I like the way you're thinking
that would have been legit with that oh
man you can block the guy from coming up
but you don't want that right you want
to kill him right now and pulling that
guy's not gonna do you any good because
he's gonna hit the other building then
oh I wish I could go here and then ya
pull them into the water can't though
that's cool I never thought about
pulling into like chasms and [ __ ] well
you haven't really played this squad
right no this is your first time yeah
use the rock on the building does that
work I think it's gonna damage the
building no I know can't even do it or
can you throw the rock to the one to the
past him will push him this way oh yeah
push him down yeah good point
that works push him one this way I guess
is that like how much damage does the
rock do oh the hook doesn't do any
damage either huh I don't think so
that's unfortunate pulling there that
does that is gonna hit the other
building then right I feel like if I
move him I can
something more I might have to just take
building damage or does he take damage
for running into your dude
yeah thanks so like if you positioned
him heat like next to him and then
through the rock no no next to the the
scorpion if you do the boulder at the
scorpion does he bounced off into your
guy too
yeah for three no it has to be adjacent
tiles it only does like to the side Oh
got it okay so it doesn't actually mmmm
sucks I think I just have to take some
building damage okay so all along we
were technically right I guess so get
over here
that it was bad I think cuz let's try it
no I think so
no he no I can go in water oh you want
him to attack that by the way yes I
don't think you're gonna free the five
buildings though unless I gotta kill two
guys and you definitely can feel - these
two are fine I want to kill [ __ ] no I
can't so I gotta kill two dudes and then
my last one has to it well create will
he fall through the water again I
already set my turn so I don't know so
what do I want to let him hit the
building well not not if I don't think
you're gonna get the fur the first
objective so you should be striving for
the second object
I could look if I could let him attack
that's and then attack it with one other
and they just kill one other dude with
all right you go let me let me I think
this will break him through really bad
can you move far enough to whip that guy
over there just short I'm guessing
that's not gonna work cuz your guys in
the way I should just try to kill them
or I might know I might just go for the
building instead of trying to kill the
seven guys can I doesn't look that way
I felt both of them why did the rock
break that last time I don't know man
Matteo what the [ __ ]
kill him that's six there's anybody kill
this grappling hook tank is very
technical
okay maybe because the ice is kind of
broken maybe if you pull it on to the
broken ice it'll it'll die this point I
have nothing to lose
dang it why why do the rock break it
that other time I'm just I'm gonna hurt
my guy - I don't there another life lost
it in background wait who your your tank
guy oh [ __ ] all right whatever it
doesn't matter we screwed screwed it up
what a big botch fest right there and
that's you know I think that's what we
call it Mike
unless you got some upgrade stuff that
you want to show off before really I
don't think I got Matteo the last time
the ice was already broken it didn't
look like it cuz that was the whole
reason why we like stopped ourselves
fine even I think they're sayin ice has
two HP and it already had one done and
then the rock did one more I guess so I
don't know like that squad there they
require different kind of thinking and
got to be quick quadrant quadrant um
that was cool though like you see how it
gets much deeper later on especially
with new squad yeah and and each
environment kind of depending like it's
like multiple layers I like the
environment already plays a factor but
depending on your squad like yet the
grappling hook guy like that's gonna do
different things the boulder guy does
different things so and there's like how
many squads like nine yeah so there's
already there's a lot to explore there
$15 comes out tomorrow so steam gog and
I Oh s apparently yeah and I think if
you want to check out Edie
Edmund trans review he gave it a 9 out
of 10 on GameSpot so yeah Mike's
enjoying it I'm sure there's a few folks
in the chat that were pretty happy about
- so thanks Mike for playing that was
awesome yeah thanks for introducing
learning - me too yeah awesome and we'll
be back tomorrow so we'll see you guys
every day at 11:00 a.m. for the rest of
the weeks and Saturday Sunday
I could have grappled him and then
that would have made more sense I just
got trigger-happy with the Tesla guy
yeah I mean yeah whatever it's fine
first time anyways thanks guys see you
later thanks my bog
[Music]